like Masters is running in the other big
race in the state of Arizona which like
the governor's race is still nowhere
near being settled Master says he can
still win his race he says there is
evidence of true screw-ups in ballot
Counting
counted ballots uncounted ballots
somehow getting commingled into the same
pile so we asked Arizona officials for
response to these claims we've heard
nothing back from them Blake Masters
joins us now like Masters thank you so
much for coming on so tell us what you
believe happened in some cases to
ballots in Maricopa County Arizona
well first of all Tucker we're in a dog
fight here in Arizona my race will be
very very close it's going to be decided
by a few thousand votes either way so
there's hundreds of thousands of ballots
outstanding and they haven't been
counted yet which apparently is hard for
Maricopa County I mean things are just
so incompetent here the problems started
Tuesday morning when 20 to 30 percent of
the voting tabulation machines didn't
work this wasn't a surprise when
election day was it it just didn't work
I mean what the heck is that right
incompetence at the very worst but then
it got worse so people when they uh got
to a machine and the Machine didn't work
they were invited to just drop their
ballet ballot in a secure box hey we'll
count this later well it turns out
Maricopa County on at least two
occasions mixed up those uncounted
ballots with ballots that had already
been counted so it's a giant disaster
it's a giant mess to try to unmix these
ballots right I think the most honest
thing at this point would be for
Maricopa County to wipe the Slate clean
and just take all the ballots and do a
fresh count we'll see if they do that
but it's just incompetent how could they
not do that I mean how could it be
considered a legitimate election outcome
whether you win or lose but just if you
care about democracy you would demand
that every vote is counted and not
double counted correct
that's exactly right I think arizonans
deserve much much better and when Kerry
lake is Governor they're going to get it
so Maricopa County elections maybe
they're working hard God bless them it's
at best just incompetent but you know
what else is incompetent Tucker The
Establishment right the people who
control the purse strings Senate
leadership fund Mitch McConnell
McConnell decided to spend millions of
dollars attacking a fellow Republican in
Alaska instead of helping me defeat
Senator Mark Kelly had he chosen to
spend money in Arizona this race would
be over we'd be celebrating a senate
majority right now and so my message to
the people of America my message to
actually my the Republican Senators
hopefully my future colleagues let's not
vote Mitch McConnell into leadership he
doesn't deserve to be Majority Leader or
minority leader you get a choice you can
stand with your constituents and stand
with Americans or you can stand for
Mitch McConnell Tucker if I'm lucky
enough to represent Arizona in the U.S
Senate next year I think it's clear
where I'll stand
why wouldn't I mean he spent money on
primaries in Alaska this is one of the
big Senate races in the country and he
avoided it why wouldn't he support you I
wonder
I will leave it to the viewer to decide
whether it is just malice or whether
it's gross incompetence but clearly
Mitch McConnell cares about Mitch
McConnell and less about a senate
majority or the people of America I
think we need to change that's why I ran
for office in one way or another change
is coming
amazing like Masters thank you so much
thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight